hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring in this video we're going to
talk about how to study for the ECT math
section so we're going to go through
resources we're gonna go through just an
approach for how to prepare so that
you're ready when you take the math
section of the AC T okay so first of all
let's talk about some resources so
there's three things I'm going to
mention to you actually maybe four
different things I'm going to mention to
you as far as you know getting your
resources in in line so that you can
start your studying process so first of
all there are some guides that are out
there
one that's a classic is this one right
here it's the real a CT prep guide and
this guide has got five tests that were
previously released by the AC T so these
are what the tests are going to look
pretty close to so if you understand
these tests really well you're gonna be
in a better position to do well on the
math section of the AC T so this is one
guy that's the real AC T guide then for
this year okay you've got the 2016 and
2017 official AC t-- prep guide and this
guy's got I believe two or three tests
in it and again these are also
previously released tests actual tests
that were administered by the AC T so
this is also a very good guide to have
and then other guides that you can you
know if you're looking for additional
practice there's the Princeton Review
puts out a guide Barron's Kaplan all
those tests companies put out guys this
particular one is mcgraw-hill and it's
got ten a CT practice tests you can get
some more practice with this guide as
well and then I also have a guide of my
own I put together a video course as I
call it a huge a CT math review and it
goes through 65 important concepts that
are covered on the test and I'll have a
link for that if you're interested in
checking that out but then let's talk
about how to actually study for the test
so the main thing you want to understand
when you're getting ready for the math
section of the AC T is that there's 60
questions and that you're given 60
minutes
so essentially what that works out to is
a minute per question right but the
thing is is that at the very beginning
of the test there's going to be some
very easy
questions and as you go through it it
gets progressively you know more
challenging you're probably going to
need to set aside more time to do those
more difficult problems near the end now
you don't necessarily have to assume
that the problems that are at the end
are gonna be harder than the ones at the
beginning sometimes for some students
they're actually easier because those
are problems that you've already done
and worked on in your math class so
you're already familiar it's fresh in
your mind and that sort of thing so
don't get psyched out by those problems
they come out late in the exam thinking
that they're going to be impossible
oftentimes they're they're very easy for
you but the thing to realize is that
when you're going through the the
tehsils first few questions what makes
them easier is because they're like
one-step problems it just requires you
maybe to you know add some fractions or
just do some simple order of operations
and then what happens is as you go
through the say from question 1 through
10 to maybe like 20 to the 30 or 30 to
40 then they start to get to be like 2
step 3 step 4 step type questions where
you were gonna have to do an operation
and then use that answer to do another
operation it's just gonna be more
multi-step and then there's more room
for error because of those multiple
steps so that's just something to pay
attention to now the other thing that
you want to do is you want to allocate
time to actually you know time yourself
when you do these tests and the very
beginning what you might want to do is
just take one of the release practice
tests just go through it you know don't
time yourself just get used to the
questions and just you know go through
it see which one's you're getting wrong
and you know that kind of thing just to
get a feel for the test just to get a
feel for the format of the test then
what you can do after you do that maybe
a couple of times is then you can start
timing yourself say you know how's my
timing I'm like you know I'm not getting
done in 60 minutes do I have time to go
back and look through some of the
questions or am i or am i running out of
time and I'm leaving a lot of questions
that are fairly easy that I should have
been able to get you know on the table
so to speak so that's what you want to
do is first just take the test then go
back and practice the timing and the
thing that you want to realize with the
time is that the questions at the very
beginning those should only take you
maybe 20 seconds so that's going to
leave an extra 40 seconds that you can
use for problems you know in addition to
that average one minute per question
near the end of the test so timing is an
important thing the other thing is a lot
of students they'll just take one
practice test they'll go into the
and say hey you know I'm ready and you
really don't want to do that you want to
take multiple tests you want to see
which problems that you're getting wrong
and the other thing too is that when
you're doing the problems you want to be
able to identify to yourself either say
it out loud or make a note say this
problem is testing me on blank whether
it's proportions or it's testing me on
functions or whether it's you know
graphing or it's you know factoring
whatever the type of topic it is if you
can identify it in your mind or write it
down and you're realizing those problems
are the ones that are tripping up each
time you're going to need to go back and
go over those concepts some more to
solidify your understanding of those
concept areas but what happens on the
ECT is it's not that it's that much more
challenging in your math class it's just
that the questions are in a slightly
different format they're not going to
come out and say you know hey John I
just wanted to let you know you know
this question is a midpoint question
they're not going to say that they might
make some kind of reference to halfway
or they might say something about you
know the middle but they might not say
use the midpoint formula to solve this
problem it's up to you you know to
recognize that yeah this is a midpoint
problem and you're going to get that
understanding as you do more problems
and you start to realize oh yeah this is
a distance formula problem let me you
know get out my distance formula and go
ahead and go to it but what makes it
difficult it again is just trying to
recognize okay let me take these this
word problem okay and then put it into
you know a format that I know how to
just go ahead and evaluate simplify you
know do the process to get to the to the
answer now there's a lot of test taking
strategies and a lot of videos I'm sure
that you've been watching I've been
showing you all these little tips and
tricks and techniques and strategies for
just guessing right and I'm not a super
big proponent of that although it does
have its place like when you're solving
maybe systems of equations it's easier
just to take those answers put them back
into the equations see which ones work
that's going to be a faster strategy so
you can always do that back substitution
technique where you you take the ABCDE
and you just go ahead and plug them back
in but I definitely recommend you know
knowing how to solve the problems having
a good grasp of that then you can go
ahead and implement those little
shortcut strategies like like plugging
back in the
sir so other things that I want to talk
to you about as far as preparing for the
exam is that I know students are
oftentimes busy you know I'm sure you're
busy studying for your regular classes
and the last thing you want to do is you
know study for the acct right you just
want to get it done get it over with but
if you're trying to get into a good
school or maybe you're on the borderline
of getting into your desired school or
you know your to your math section score
is really pulling down your overall a CT
score what you want to do is you want to
break it up into small sections I mean
whether you're just doing maybe let's
say ten problems of one test every day
very manageable you just set aside ten
minutes every day you do those ten
problems you know you check them and
then okay next day you do ten more
problems sometimes it's overwhelming for
students to say I don't I don't have an
hour to sit down and do this test and
then spend another hour going through it
and reviewing it just too much so break
it down into small pieces so that you
it's manageable I mean if you have to
get down to the point where you're doing
one question a day as long as you're
doing it you're sticking to a schedule
you know and a month are gonna cover you
know 30 questions ideally would be
better if you could do ten questions so
that in a month's time you're going
through 300 questions which is
equivalent of five tests which is the
equivalent of going through this entire
relay CT prep guide because there's five
tests in here so again we're just
focusing on the math section but you
probably have some tips and tricks to
strategy yourself if you're watching
this video go ahead and put those in the
comments below to help other students
that are watching this video to get some
other ideas about what they can do to
prepare and again if you're interested
in purchasing the huge a CT math review
video course that I have available check
out the links for that there's three
lessons that you can preview to see if
it's right for you you can get a sense
of you know what's my teaching styles
like and how the video course would be
but it's three and a half hours it's not
very expensive something that could
benefit you if you're just looking to
review a lot of those old math concepts
that you may have forgotten but again
put some comments in the comments below
if you have some other suggestions to
other students I'm sure they'll
appreciate that as well I and I look
forward to seeing in the future videos
check out more videos regarding the ECT
on my mario's math tutor and youtube
channel and subscribe to the channel and
I look forward to seeing in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon